Welcome to Table Talk, where each week I unpack insights from Christian theology and spirituality
that help you become a thoughtful, contemplative, and just a downright great human being.
My name's Brett Tilford, and today is part two of our series on how to handle relational
conflict.
So, the title of this episode is Bumping Into Myself.
That's a phrase I got from Dr. Frank Green, who taught at the seminary I attended, Portland
Seminary, and it's been super illuminating for me.
And the reason why is because it reveals that when I become emotionally reactive, my
tendency is to shift the blame onto someone or something else.
For example, I often get mad at my dog, Biscuit.
Why?
Well, I say it's because he is the worst.
He doesn't obey.
He's so annoying.
He's so terrible.
But the truth is that when I become emotionally reactive to my dog, Biscuit, it's not about
Biscuit.
Is it?
Who's it about?
Me.
I want to say it's him, but actually, I'm bumping into myself.
And perhaps you have a spouse, a boss, a friend, or an ex-spouse or boss or friend that you
find yourself not merely disagreeing with, but becoming highly emotionally reactive to.
They just make you so hacked off or depressed or whatever, and what you're tempted to say
is, of course, it's them.
It's their bad attitude.
It's their immaturity.
It's their insensitivity.
It's their utter stupidity.
Now, there may be truth in what you're saying.
In fact, for the sake of argument, I'll go along with it.
They can be negative and immature and insensitive and stupid, but that has no bearing on your
emotional response.
And when you respond in a reactive, angry, insecure, frustrated, fearful way, you're
not bumping into them, you're bumping into you.
So how does this insight help us navigate conflict?
Well, bumping into myself helps me realize two things.
First, I understand that the issue is rarely the issue.
I say the reason I'm freaking out is because of them or this situation, but no.
The reason I'm freaking out is because of me.
I'm prone to insecurity and fear.
There is an obscure yet illuminating story in the Bible.
It's found in the book of Numbers, chapter 12.
You may have heard of Moses, you know, the famous Ten Commandments, let my people go,
that guy.
So contrary to popular knowledge, he wasn't a lone ranger sort of leader, but he actually
had two other key leaders who helped him tremendously.
In fact, they were his brother and his sister, Aaron and Miriam.
Now, you probably haven't heard much about Aaron and Miriam because, well, they were
a bit more behind the scenes, which leads to the story in Numbers, chapter 12, verses
1 through 2.
And I quote,
Miriam and Aaron began to talk against Moses because of his Cushite wife, for he had married
a Cushite.
Verse 2, has the Lord spoken only through Moses, they asked, hasn't he also spoken through
us?
And the Lord heard this.
Now, notice the weird juxtaposition of verses 1 and then verse 2, right?
Verse 1 says they began to talk against Moses.
Now, who were they talking to?
We're not really sure.
Perhaps simply to one another, though I sort of doubt it.
You know how humans are.
It's likely they began talking to others about Moses.
And by the way, Cushite means Ethiopian, so it's possible there's some racism or ethnocentrism,
i.e. like cultural superiority going on.
But then in verse 2, they move on to another topic.
Has the Lord spoken only through Moses?
Hasn't he spoken through us too?
Now, we're starting to get closer to the root issue, right?
Well, was the issue Moses' marriage to a foreigner?
I don't think so.
Or was the issue that Moses was the favorite and they were playing second fiddle?
Well, again, I think that's getting closer to the truth, but no.
Instead, what was the issue that pushed them to gossip about Moses?
Their own insecurity.
They were bumping into themselves and the issues.
He married a Cushite, and was he the only important one around here?
They weren't really the primary issues.
It was them and their own feelings of inferiority.
That's the first insight that the knowledge that I'm bumping into myself creates.
All of a sudden, I see the issue is rarely the issue.
The second realization that comes as a result of understanding I'm bumping into myself is
that others are bumping into themselves too.
Now, I want to nuance this because I'm not saying that any time someone comes to you
with feedback, you should say, whoa, Susie, this isn't about me.
This is about you, my friend.
Of course not, right?
Feedback about who we are is essential.
But I'm talking about when someone is highly emotionally reactionary, right?
Once they are freaking out, they've been hijacked.
So, do not take it personally.
In fact, the more emotionally reactive they are, it makes it just that much more likely
that it's not about you at all.
It's them.
It's their fear, their insecurity, their past pain.
Now, what's so liberating about this insight is that we tend to do the opposite.
If someone reacts, then we're like, oh my, oh, I must pay attention to them.
Whereas if they're calm, then we think, ah, it's not that big a deal.
No, no, no, no.
It's the opposite.
If they're calm, take their feedback seriously.
But if they're freaking out, chill, right?
They're simply bumping into themselves, and it might be wise if you remove yourself from
that situation.
So, the next time you're tempted to freak out, remember, you're bumping into yourself.
And when someone else is freaking out on you, don't react.
Don't take it personally.
Just realize they're bumping into themselves too.
Well, that's all for today.
If you enjoyed this content, please click the Like button and comment below.
And if you know someone who could benefit from it, go ahead and share it with them.
Grace and peace.